the topic that has been the dominant
focus of the things that need to be
changed the competition committee
proposing
and this is a one-year experimental type
thing meaning you get you need 24 votes
to make it happen for one year and next
year you need another 24 votes to keep
it in place it's not a permanent rule
change but reviewable plays would be
expanded to include
roughing the passer to include past
interference to include unnecessary
contact against players in a defenseless
position this is the response peter to
what happened in the nfc championship
game
although if it passes it doesn't prevent
what happened in the nfc championship
game because it only applies when the
flag is thrown it's not available for
when there's a non-call which
i i
we're going to be talking more about
this later but i don't get it they they
found the problem they've implemented a
potential fix and it wouldn't have
avoided what actually happened to cause
the problem to be addressed in the first
place what's going on here
mike my many years of covering what the
competition committee does and in trying
to read the tea leaves in the
relationship between
roger goodell troy vincent
rich mckay and the competition committee
and when i saw this last night
my first reaction was a very simple one
these guys don't have the votes
they don't have the votes
to fix the problem that happened in the
nfc championship game
that isn't to say that what is written
right here
because there have been many times
when
uh rules
rules proposals can be fixed and can be
adjusted either now or in may
at the league meetings when they have
their spring meetings in key biscayne
florida so
mike i don't think this is a final thing
but i do think that it is disturbing
that these guys have had basically two
months
to try to address try to find a way to
address a problem that may have sent the
wrong team to the super bowl and this is
what they've come up with because it's
not satisfactory and i'll just add one
other thing mike
at the nfl scouting combine recently i
ran into a member of the competition
committee
and i and we talked about what might
happen the sky judge all this other
stuff
the one thing he said is roger goodell
is not going to allow us to leave
phoenix unless
there is a tangible fix to the problem
those are my words not his i forget his
exact quote but but roger goodell is
going to make us fix this problem so
let's see what the commissioner can do
in phoenix
well and i've got some thoughts on that
as well we're going to take a closer
look at this wrinkle at this problem and
this failed effort to try to fix it at
least so far in about a half hour
another important proposal that that
i think should get more consideration
than maybe it will i don't know what
will happen when it comes from the other
conference championship game we've seen
it twice now in the last three years
where a team in a championship setting
wins the toss in overtime drive down the
field scores a touchdown and wins the
game in both instances it was the
patriots super bowl 51 and the 2018 afc
title game in kansas city the chiefs
proposing a rule change that would
ensure possession for both teams
even if the team that gets the ball
first scores a touchdown peter look this
is not a competition committee proposal
so it's got far less
juice it's got far less cachet than it
would have as it makes its way to the
floor for consideration by the owners i
don't think it's going to go anywhere
but i still think there is a basic
inequity that arises
at an age where it's so much easier to
play offense than it's ever been because
the response is play defense play
defense it's easy to play offense the
idea that in the post season you can
advance to the next level and knock a
team out and keep their offense on the
field for the entirety of overtime and
it's one drive and you score a touchdown
that doesn't sit well with me
i don't think it it has the same
reaction among owners and i don't think
this is going to change but i think it
should
mike when you say a quote
basic inequity
you know that's like
saying uh you know the ransom is one
million dollars you know i mean i mean
you know basically basically mike what
we're talking about right here
it when you say basic inequity
i mean anybody who knows anything about
football and who watch the afc
championship game and i'm looking and
i'm calling it up right now because it's
totally insane you know the the the the
chiefs in the fourth quarter of this
game went 62 yards for a touchdown 23
yards for a touchdown
68 yards for a touchdown 48 yards for a
field goal and sent it to overtime was
there any doubt in your mind that a if
the chiefs had won the toss they would
have elected to receive and b
if the chiefs had won the toss they
would have gone down and scored
and and this isn't and i've had this
discussion with a lot of people over the
last few weeks and they say oh oh you're
just angry because the mvp didn't get
the ball in overtime well i mean i mean
i i suppose so i i think i would like to
see patrick mahomes in overtime in the
afc championship game yes call me
perverse
but i mean honestly mike
who in the world
who in the world thinks it's a fair
system a fair system
for a coin flip
to determine the possession of the ball
at the start of overtime
and that could be the only possession of
overtime i understand a lot of people do
that defense yeah that's what drives me
crazy my defense play defense it's it's
crazy
then why why
in my memory mike
i think the patriots did it once against
the colts and and uh rod marinelli did
it against the chicago bears why at the
start of overtime in my memory anyway
and it might be more
has there only been twice
in my memory ever
that a team at the start of overtime has
won the toss and elected to kick off why
if there's no advantage to having the
ball at the start of overtime why
wouldn't you just kick off if you love
your defense answer that one
yeah and i agree with you completely
look there needs to be a guaranteed
possession for both teams even if the
team that has the ball first like the
saints in the nfc championship game
throw an interception it doesn't matter
there needs to be that fairness built
into this now we're going to talk more
about this later peter i i don't
necessarily and i'm going to go farther
than that i don't believe that this
change should apply to regular season
overtime because unintended consequences
really would happen there and i think
that sudden death is fine for the
regular season for me though when you're
talking about the postseason when you're
talking about the season ending for one
team i think there needs to be that
ability to answer what the other team
does on the first drive of overtime if
that's all they do for the postseason
only and go back to sudden death for the
regular season i'd be perfectly fine
with it
mike and and what uh what i really like
about the rules proposals that we've
seen the best thing
is to eliminate overtime in pre-season
games because what the league is
basically saying to the players
association is hey
we heard your complaint
about putting players on the field for
more plays potentially so that they
might get injured we heard that
and we are going to respond to it so
no overtime in the preseason even though
it's a bit of a trojan horse because no
starters would be playing in overtime
anyway
but i am absolutely fine
with making a change with with with
changing this out mike that either it be
sudden death
uh at the start of overtime uh in in
regular season games or or
that you play that as you got to score a
touchdown to win
in the ring in in in
you know in overtime but in the playoffs
both teams should have a possession it's
too important
it'd be more fun if we disagreed about
this but we're on the same page and
hopefully somebody out there is
listening and heeding this because you
know we both have the best interest of
the game at mind and sometimes i just
think there's too many chefs there's too
many people there's too many agendas
there's too much that that loot you
cause the focus the very simple focus to
get lost and i feel like that happens
with the competition committee
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports